let's talk about government power
spending with this next story from the
daily mail
revealed fauci is america's highest paid
federal employee on 417
608 dollar salary after joking an
interview with matt mcconaughey
that he was just a government worker on
a government salary
so uh how do i get one of those
government salaries gosh
they say fauci is the nation's highest
paid federal employee ranking in
417 000 in 2019 which is the latest year
that federal salary date is available
he made more than the president's four
hundred thousand dollar
a year salary excuse me in 2019 he also
made more than mike pence who outranks
fauci in authority
and made 235 thousand one hundred
dollars in salary as well as doctor
deborah burks who made 305 000.
if fauci remains in this position and
doesn't get a raise he'll make 2.5
million dollars
from 2019 through 2024. i don't know why
they picked those years but i guess it's
because of the next term
data shows that the highest federal
employees were medical and dental
officers
why are we paying look look you can talk
about dr fauci
and his right or wrong and lockdowns and
all stuff but why are we paying these
people so much money
it's not just about fauci it's about
just all of these people in general
getting
hundreds of thousands of dollars from
the taxpayer
for what the because they're friends
with the people that make the rules
that dole out the finance and it's free
money for them because it's tax money
they don't have to
know us to take our money they just get
it so that's funny though because i'm
actually i thought those numbers would
be even worse
because at the state and local level
like at the university level
a university president at least at where
i went umass
makes north of 650 000
right the basketball coach at umass
which sucked and lost
most of its games made a million dollars
when i was there he made more than the
president
and these are all government employees
made more than the governor of
massachusetts the public
yeah they're all these are all taxpayer
funded and so
if you listen if you can't succeed in
business
go to government and because they
actually the funny thing about
government is how they advance and how
they do raises
is not based on merit it's literally
just based all right all right
i'll say this tax money going to
these people to pay them exorbitant
salaries is theft
yeah there we go i've been working on
you for a while
we did it folks let's celebrate tim
ferguson
because the i think the idea of taxing
is fine the problem is when the
government's corrupt then it's not being
used for what it's supposed to be
supposed to be used for you can make all
these arguments all the margins in the
world
from the left about taxes are good it's
like paying a subscription to receive
the roads and the safety and
the clean water and i'm like sure if
that's what was used for
am i supposed look i got no problem with
taxes the pro the pro
i have no price with the concept of
paying taxes the problem i have is how
much is going to blow up kids
how much is going to pay this this
dude's salary for the basketball team
which this point like what's
why are you getting a million dollars
but that's the thing is in concept that
makes sense but government is
always going to be corrupt show me the
government that isn't corrupt
government power centralized power by
its very nature
corrupts even good people though good
people are usually not drawn to high
office and running for power this is
public choice theory
in economics it self selects for the
people that are the most ambitious
and most ruthless they're the only ones
that can get to the top of the food
chain
so government corruption is not a bug it
is the system
yeah very good point that you made there
now there are some people arguing that
we should pay
politicians and government officials a
high amount so they don't get bribed by
special interests
not but but this definitely seems
exorbitant
to say the least uh dr fauci i mean i'm
definitely not a fan of him uh
especially everything he did at the
wuhan laboratory
specifically trying to make coronavirus
uh
as lethal as it could be with the gain
of function data studies
uh but you know there there's an
argument to be made that you don't want
these people working for other interests
but
as i've been arguing against that saying
you know money corrupts individuals and
you never have enough so
even if you do pay them a lot you know
what's the middle ground here where do
we meet in the middle
to make sure that they're satisfied and
that they're not corrupt because i mean
essentially let's let's ask ourselves
what what did dr fauci do
i mean he's repeating a lot of the world
health organization kind of directives
and talking points but those keep
flip-flopping all the time
a lot of the projections were wrong i
think it's very fair to say that the
united states handling of this entire
situation has been extremely
poor so when you have something that is
not done right
you shouldn't be paying top dollar for
it well and that's the problem is with
businesses if they mess up and they then
guess what they go
under business or if an employee messes
up big time they get fired but think
about it like this the cdc
literally blocked all coveted testing at
the beginning and said only you can only
use our test
right but then their test didn't work
and it took them months before they
allowed private labs
to go and make tests again the cdc did
not lose any money from their budget
from that
exactly they didn't get cut they didn't
get shrunk like a private business that
bombed that bad would probably go out of
business or
boycott it or even dr fauci that told
you that masks are bad
that you shouldn't wear masks dr fauci
literally was telling you that
flip-flopping all the time under the
directives of the world health
organization which he
just a couple days ago was very excited
that the united states is going to be
back a part of and
financing and funding even though they
don't even recognize taiwan as a country
which is absolutely ridiculous we also
have to talk about the
fouchy fetish like the media and some of
the liberals
not like some people just like him right
but some people have gotten like culty
with it yeah like they have like
fouchy i've seen fouchy sex toys
yes i've seen like glowing profiles of
him about how he's like a stud and a
and all these memes that are like sort
of joking sexualization
screws you over literally and
figuratively
you guys sense this like cult worship
with like who's the new
it's like greta thundberg 2.0 who's
who's the new celebrity it's
uh this guy fauci they're like oh it's
this guy
let's oh no now it's kamala harris let's
let's worship
kamala here well to be fair brad pitt
did play dr
fauci on snl good for him so i mean if
if you're looking at those kind of
accreditations you don't have much
accreditation what did dr fauci do
during this entire saga that we've been
through that actually made a positive
impact into
the coronavirus i mean that's a serious
legitimate question that we need to be
asking especially if he's getting paid
that much i mean can you name anything
noble or great that he's done with the
coronavirus other than just repeat world
health organization talking points and
and contradict himself all the time well
we don't know what he's done behind the
scenes
and i i imagine he seems like a good guy
i think he's done his best and it was
like a super
horrible position to be in right no one
knew how to handle it but no one can say
he didn't make a ton of mistakes he
he did and we should be allowed to point
those out and ask
what the consequences are yeah is there
going to be any accountability is there
going to be
any way to uh get you know
justice for some of the larger
consequences that are
leading because of very bad government
mistakes well so
here's the thing that bothers me the
most about fauci and some of these other
public health people is they were saying
they changed their tune and they act
like they never did
so for example you mentioned masks and
that's a good one but also schools yeah
schools
rand paul and a bunch of other people
and science was showing this to in other
countries
that reopening schools was perfectly
safe and fine and fouchy
and other people were totally against it
and then they just pivoted
a month or two ago they've really
pivoted hardcore since the election and
about lockdowns and that's what i can't
stand is it i feel a little gas-lit by
it all
yep you may have heard some chiming i
don't know if that was coming through
the podcast but it's because i was
scouring the web to try and find that
story about fauci and the research and i
got it to newsweek.com
dr fauci backed controversial wuhan lab
with us dollars for risky coronavirus
research
his newsweek how have i never heard that
this is newsweek that tells you that a
lot that i've never heard that story
from april 28th of last year they say dr
fauci is an advisor to trump
last year the national institute of
allergy and infectious diseases led by
fouchy
funded scientists at the wuhan institute
of virology and other institutions
for work on gain of function research on
bat coronaviruses yes
what it what well the particular the
particular bats that are in question
here that many scientists and experts
point to uh leading to the coronavirus
are thousands of miles away from wuhan
so the possibility of these bats
traveling specifically to
wuhan is extremely improbable now do we
have any empirical evidence showing that
there's a direct
link to this no there's a crap ton of
circumstantial evidence highlighting
exactly
that there could have been an accident
okay people were selling them
people were taking animals to the wet
markets that's what they're saying
there is from i think new york mag what
they call the lab league hypothesis
we don't know for sure exactly we don't
know for sure but there is a lot of
circumstantial evidence that a lot of
experts are looking at and pointing to
and saying
they were literally working on making
the coronavirus
jump uh from species to species making
it as dangerous as possible
uh that this is where the term gain of
function comes from this is
what dr fauci was literally in charge of
bankrolling
uh you know before the coronavirus so
this and the united states there was
even diplomatic leaked cables
saying that there's a high probability
of a virus leaking
from this wuhan laboratory before the
corona virus
and just to clarify this is from the
intelligence or new york mag the lab
leak hypothesis for decades scientists
have been hot-wiring viruses
in hopes of preventing a pandemic not
causing one but what if
and that's basically what he brings up
that there are many scientists saying
that
essentially the hypothesis is they were
trying to create vaccines
and then there was a breach of some sort
but i'm not saying that's true
if you read it in the new york mag take
it from them beloved sometimes you need
a crisis
man we couldn't get into syria the
weapons of mass destruction weren't
quite enough you know 9 11 got people
riled up but there has a vacuuming
yeah just to rally everyone to become
subservient you know soldiers or
for the cause or whatever well the
reason this is important to me because
if we could understand the origin of
this sickness we could deal with it
so the real issue right now is china
blocking the world health organization
or the researchers who want to come in
around a year china has blocked the
world health organization the world
health organization that sings its
praises that says that china did an
amazing job with the coronavirus they
are even being blocked from coming in
and just a few days ago finally
after i believe three or four official
very public
uh attempts that china grant the world
health health organization
access into the supposed wet market well
china re-opened
the wet markets yes that's the craziest
part about all of this these wet markets
are notoriously
unhygienic and dangerous for diseases
and jumping and this happened
came coming from one it was at least the
original hypothesis
they reopened them they don't they
evidently don't care and another thing
that bothers me actually as a journalist
is i see all the time
china's numbers just uncritically
parroted like the headline will be
china new crate case numbers has kovit
under control
or china's economic numbers i'm
particularly suspicious of their like
rosy economy in china as a rest of world
struggles
and i'm like you're just repeating
according to communist party officials
um well hold on you just said you're not
going to question that
you think that those are just
trustworthy figures you can just
accept as fact think about how many
journalists in the united states
all of a sudden became the cheerleaders
for the u.s intelligence apparatus when
donald trump got elected all of a sudden
everything the government said was true
and correct all the time how many
leftists made that switch
too they're like and also they were kind
of right like decades ago saying like
the war on terror
they're infringing civil liberties and
then it was like oh they're spying on
trump
heck yeah like well that's okay
now it's really funny because you got
some lefties who are like you know what
we mentioned the journalists with
sending the troops how dare you then
they send in the troops to d.c that's a
good thing and there's a good reason for
it
okay and they're keeping them there up
until
march or maybe even indefinitely because
of a supposed
threat again a threat it's the
impeachment trap what did jack bosobic
say he's like
the military will will remain occupying
the city until the opposition leader's
trial is is over
that's just absolutely crazy so i
actually went i actually went into the
city when this was all locked down and
everything and i had to like get an
uber to go somewhere to do something for
my job right and he could only get me
within a mile to where i needed to go
because there was like
swat team not even swat teams but like
military trucks
blocking the road and put up fences and
i had to walk the rest of the way
like just get the uber i got the uber
like within a mile and i was like i
guess i'll just walk
what day was that oh that was like two
days before inauguration
uh it wasn't on inauguration day and it
wasn't even particularly close to the
capitol or anything it was like a couple
miles from there
have they toned down the security
somewhat but so they reopened the
highways and they reopened the bridges
they literally closed the bridges from
arlington
to dc like you just couldn't go across
and i was like
how are people who are essential workers
supposed to
do that this whole this the shutting
down of the economy in the world is is
really kind of crazy i was
my conspiratorial mind is like lit up
the last few days particularly the last
few days for some reason thinking about
wuhan and corona because obviously
corona is nasty
but where it came from totally up for
debate and
we should talk about it because
bioweapons we've been making movies
about them for 20 years and it's like it
is a terrifying idea i just
i just think it's so disruptive to the
world economy i mean
it's just listen grinding things to us
you're confusing the virus with the
government well i'm thinking of
thinking about the response to the virus
what i'm most concerned with right what
we know about covet is a 99.99 survival
rate for people under what 70
70 years old yeah so it's it's question
the question is the government response
rate
now they're they're adjusting the pcr
test threshold
that was the world health organization
that even it's it's not it's
look you know people have gotten sick i
know people who have gotten sick with it
and i know and and i know people who
have had family members die with it
right i think the reality is never let a
good crisis go to waste
it's just simple it's the government saw
an opportunity to exploit us because
there was something happening
so like well and government also they
they never think of the unintended
consequences right so they see the
problem they swing the hammer
but it's like i saw a study the other
day actually and this was in the
national bureau of economic research
saying that 850 000 excess deaths will
be caused from the covid related
unemployment
and that's mostly from the lockdowns not
from the disease what is that like in a
over a year over the next 15 years from
un
from suicides from depression from heart
issues
like this isn't documented trend in
economics that unemployment causes
health issues poverty causes health
issues and so and that's just one thing
yeah
that's not counting suicide drug that's
not counting
um marital violence and domestic
violence and the children of all the
people that that will affect so if 850
000 people
are are going to kill themselves or die
what about all their kids
right there's another 16 million people
yeah but it's all these second order
unintended consequences when they just
looked at one thing and they didn't
consider anything else and then they
refused to adapt
also that's the original i think the
original mistake you have to give some
grace for what's bothered me is the fact
that they've doubled down on failed
tactics they haven't adapted
and they got promoted for it and never
held accountable for it the other study
that i saw was done by duke harvard and
john hopkins professors and they talked
about an excess of 1 million debts
coming in the future because of the
longer effects of these
lockdowns and again that's not even
including the health screenings
the stoppage of cancer treatments mental
health
illnesses and a large number of economic
illnesses that are going to be happening
as of course people have to deal with
the larger consequences of a failing
economy losing their jobs losing their
businesses
and having failing wages with just
record medical care don't forget the
kids
who have lost school and have it shut
down they will this will
like you you will look back at the
trends 10 years from now and you'll see
like a distinct
class of children who were screwed over
by this and it will show in their
lifetime success
because you can't miss a year and a half
of school and just that's fine
a lot of these kids are committing
suicide or at least trying to i saw a
terrifying story about that about a
school that reopened i can't remember
the details but a school that reopened
because it had a suicide spike among its
students and they're like we have to
reopen this was a private school
and you can't do this to kids especially
when they're
we're also transferring it because
they're not the ones at risk here
at all and so we're transferring the
cost to them
for the benefits for other subsets of
society i think that's one of them
because there's been even some studies
showing that there's no benefit towards
lockdowns and that
lockdowns actually may create certain
situations where people
accumulate together at walmart or target
or
costco and therefore could even help
spread the sickness even further so
there's even
medical there's showing that lockdowns
don't work and part of it
is this right so i got really frustrated
by new york city in
cuomo he ordered restaurants to close
they were at 25
capacity they were getting some people
could go to restaurants but it was
limited it was
super safety measures but the state's
own data showed that only 1.4
of covid cases were coming from
restaurants most coveted cases were
coming from private interpersonal
household gatherings
well guess what happens when you shut
down the restaurants people have more
gatherings
like these people actually made this
worse by shutting down businesses so not
only did they slap
new york entrepreneurs in the face but
they also probably made covetours
you also see riots breaking out which
talk about destroying people's lives
this capital riot
maybe it would have happened if there
was no corona probably not it fuels them
yeah people wouldn't be out screaming
destroying emotions if
they weren't forced to stay inside and
losing their money and their income
trump would have won if there was no
corona so not a bad argument
that's a good shot yeah i mean but he
also would have won if he handled it
better
it's true yeah he had an opportunity and
you know
interestingly trump relied too much on
fouchy for whatever reason
fauci you know what i saw him doing was
basically the media would say a day
later he'd repeat it
and that's why he ended up being wrong
so often he'd say things like oh you
shouldn't wear a mask and then two days
later
oh yeah you should wear a mask and it's
like bro they were saying that in the
news like two days ago
so the dude in my opinion for a while i
was like i like fauci he seems to be on
the level seems to be keeping a surprise
to things and then
then it kind of felt like wait a minute
this guy's like checked out isn't he
he's like super old he's been there for
decades he's getting a hundred thousand
dollars a year he's just sitting back on
like what are they saying cnn
are his eyes at half-mast because he's
zen or because he's on drugs
neither he's cause he's checked out he's
like this like dude
he recently made a statement talking
about how the numbers are plateauing and
everything
seems very promising in the united
states moving forward with covid was
this after the election
yes well also michigan dc chicago
california new york all of the
political leadership are making
announcements that they're reopening
restrictions it's just a coincidence
it's just you know
could be how many how many states was
that again how many cities uh well
there's a
there's uh dc the state of michigan the
city of chicago
california and new york the reality of
numbers that's always even when the
powerball it's only like half the
country's population you know the state
of the new york centers
you know the state of new york but but
again let's be open-minded could be a
coincidence
probability who knows let's you know we
could we could play those games at all
but but
i think it's important to have all those
possibilities open but i i agree with
your shout though like
trump definitely would have won if covet
hadn't happened because
before then people were talking about
the election in terms of socialism
versus not
wokism versus knowledge and the economy
in the economy
right but then covet it really all
became about competence and stability
and those are not trump's strong suits
those are not government's strong suits
at all when when trump was giving his
daily briefings he reached his all-time
approval rating in aggregate and then
also the media panicked and then stopped
airing them saying he was lying too much
what really happened in my opinion was
not whether or not trump did a good or
bad job it was that no matter what
happened the media said it was a bad job
now you have joe biden coming out saying
in his recent speech there's nothing we
can do
about the trajectory of covet at this
point when he said he was going to shut
it down
right while he was campaigning now
there's nothing we can do we'll hit it
hit a plan
he he said last year the travel ban
won't do anything now he's just
reinstated a travel ban the other people
in south africa right
and she actually is valid but that's
actually valid i'm pretty sure and
europe another
other it's the same travel ban trump
lifted in the first place he's doing
more travel bans
he added more countries i i i we we've
talked with lefties about this and i
said
you know basically by what metric do you
compare trump's job on the corona virus
if we were looking at the media trump
did a tremendous job because they were
saying millions would die and then
hundreds of thousands have died
and that's why conservatives republicans
when polled were like we're hap we're
okay with where things are
because they were told it was going to
be 90 you know ninety percent higher
one to two million was there i'm sorry
like ten times higher
and then it was one or two million and
then ended up being like 100 to 200 000
and people were like wow
we were warned that it was gonna be
worse trump must've done a good job but
the left just said
no all these people are dead it's the
worst possible job ignore that
no matter what he did it was wrong and
that's and then people people believe it
that's just it and you know trump's
problem is he does have he did have a
direct line to the people with twitter
but boy did he not know how to use it
look he tweeted
and it and it's something we've seen
other people do but
he didn't do it as effectively as he
could or should have and so the message
was jack dorsey can i send this message
message jack dorsey can i send this
message no he was saying can i send this
instead of
every time you tweet you're asking jack
dorsey if you're allowed to send that
message
the issue is that trump would like
attack people and he would play he'll
get caught into the flame war
that's always been his problem right a
lot of people liked it but he had an
opportunity to bypass the press and they
hated him for it
and he did many times but too often it
was just
inflammatory thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you